[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana aprovechando que
se acercan las fechas navideñas vamos a
hablar de gastronomía pero lo vamos a
hacer de una forma especial mezclando
gastronomía con política vamos a hablar
de la diplomacia de la gastronomía para
ello les presento a nuestros invitados
aitor alfonso cronista en la publicación
de food in bienvenida actor carlos
carlín champions es experta en
gastronomía bienvenida carolyn hola y
además usted se define como exploradora
de sabores qué es esto bueno es un
trabajo inventado pero hago
investigaciones sobre lo que se juegue
con la comida bueno ahora nos cuenta más
claro bienvenida y leonardo martinelli
es corresponsable el diario 'la stampa'
italiano aquí en francia bienvenido a
leonardo la la diprove la diplomacia
gastronómica o en nuestro asunto en
primera plana
[Música]
algunos la llaman diplomacia
gastronómica y otros software culinario
son términos que comienzan a ser
manejados en el mundo de las relaciones
internacionales se trata de potenciar la
cocina patria en el extranjero pero
también usar los placeres gastronómicos
para abrir puertas a contratos
multimillonarios oa mejorar la imagen de
la marca país como influyen en la imagen
de un país la gastronomía que exporta el
mundo es una pregunta de base que hoy
intentamos responder con nuestros
invitados pero antes repasemos algunas
portadas sobre el tema
diarioc ubera internacional nuevo
comienzo para la cocina internacional la
crisis sanitaria dice la publicación
hace que se tengan que reinventar los
chefs desde copenhague hasta lima esta
contraportada del diario peruano correo
con declaraciones del chef jose área
salinas diciendo que la cocina peruana
es mucho más que el ceviche este chef
plantea revalorizar la cocina peruana
por el mundo de eso vamos a hablar hoy
en el programa portal ámbito italia se
plantea como prioridad de la diplomacia
económica promover su gastronomía en el
mundo bueno lo primero tendremos muchos
oyentes y espectadores pensado bueno y
que entendemos por diplomacia
gastronómica aitor hombre pues la
diplomacia gastronómica es los medios de
la diplomacia
mediante la mesa los platos la comida es
decir es una especie de manera de
amenizar las relaciones diplomáticas y
pueden ser tensas a veces por esta
especie de espacio de lo común que sería
el comer no es la parte amena diría yo
es la cara amena de la diplomacia es
este momento simpático de la diplomacia
que poderes tiene la gastronomía como
software carolyn creo que hay que
distinguir a la gastronomía la
diplomacia gastronómica que se refiere
más al una relación entre el país y país
es decir la manera en que
los países se reciben a otro y al mismo
tiempo la gastro diplomacia que refiere
más a la la relación entre un estado y
la esfera pública es decir en la manera
en que un país invierte mucho dinero
para mí y mejorar su imagen
hacia el nuevo turismo que es algo más
revolucionario y ahí entrarían por
ejemplo las campañas internacionales
entiendo de exportar la gastronomía
patria por el mundo no sí exactamente
creo que es muy nuevo me parece se trata
de un concepto que estamos del que
hablamos ahora que nos parece novedoso
no sé si podemos fijar su inicio a
principios de los años 2000 si es algo
nuevo si es algo de lo que hablamos
ahora leonardo pero que está relacionado
con el éxito también de algunas algunos
programas de televisión como el master
chef que son globalizados ahora sí la
telerrealidad colgará ha ayudado así
porque así toda la gente en todo el
mundo conoció a la gastronomía italiana
a la francesa
y creo que esto es muy importante si
miro a italia mi país
la gastronomía es también un instrumento
de valorización económica es un negocio
porque la industria agroalimentaria
italiana es muy importante al final de
este año la facturación prevista es de
200 más de 200 visiones de mirar de
1.000 millones de euros entonces es un
negocio es una economía trabajo y
también hay también este aspecto
económico es muy importante la
gastronomía es uno de los mejores
activos de creación de imagen podríamos
decir para un país sector yo creo que sí
y no es nada nuevo recordemos que
problema en francia y esta especie de
momento un poco legendario en el que en
el congreso de viene de 1914 cuando
talegón va a negociar con los vencedores
de napoleón lo que vas lo que va a ser
europa con quien se lleva consigo a
ottón al que hay en que es el mayor
cocinero de su época y sabemos
perfectamente que lo que le dice al rey
a luís 18 es para esta reunión majestad
necesito más platos que instrucciones
políticas ya que lo que se jugó en ese
momento fue también una cuestión
alimenticia y por ejemplo es sabido en
una manera de espiar también para tal
ego porque no sabe que con el buen
yantar y él vuelve ver pues las bocas se
abren hoy los secretos se deshacen es
interesante y de hecho en esa reunión
hubo también una la primera competición
europea de quesos el conflicto político
se plasmó en el hecho de que está lego
llegó con el boeing y al bullicio el
inglés le opuso el stilton y en esa
reunión se cuenta que el voley fue
declarado rey de los quesos es curioso
ver cómo se como una plasmación
culinaria directa no de lo de las
tensiones políticas es decir un buen
plato te puede llevar a firmar un
contrato multimillonario los jefes son
también
representantes de un estilo de vida hoy
por ejemplo en italia y máximo cultura
de la serie franciscana módena en el
norte de italia que no es sólo un gran
chef es también el símbolo o un símbolo
solidario por ejemplo que es muy
importante para la imagen de una cierta
imagen moderna de italia dale aprovecha
mucho de este personaje
de ellos y no conocíamos tantos nombres
de chefs y ahora de repente
se han coreado de estado claro a como
los fútbol es con futbolistas en qué
momento cambian nos damos cuenta y toman
se revaloriza la figura del chef carolyn
en francia y en peso con la nueva cocina
la nouvelle crisis durante los años 70
pero realmente durante los años 2000 es
seguro que ha cambiado mucho el estilo
de los jefes también antes eran vestidos
con algo muy tradicional latok y todo
ahora son vestidos de moda con la barba
hablaba antes leonardo de los programas
de telerrealidad que han impulsado todo
esto pero también las publicaciones los
rankings el the best of de los 50
mejores restaurantes de los 50 mejores
chicos del mejor restaurant de cada una
de sus ciudades esto también ha puesto
en valor
la gastronomía internacional no
a ver o al crítica hacia ello carolina
yo creo es crítica a ello no es que me
parece algo muy político de lo bien
conviene y a lo mejor
bueno no no esto es muy americano
también esta idea de ranking de hacer
cuál es el mejor del mundo y todo esto
que es una
a mi parecer una idea falsa de los
países porque no refleje la comida de
los países es verdad es verdad que puede
ser una idea falsa pero todos acabamos
cayendo quizás es un perjuicio de
nuestra sociedad en notar en anotar en
dar una nota en establecer un ranking es
algo también muy propio de nuestros
tiempos que están que se ve en este
campo no nos relacionado con la
globalización y creo que la gastronomía
diplomática es relacionada también con
la globalización del gusto y sí sí
pienso a italia italia aprovecha por
ejemplo de productos que son bastante
simples a comprender comprando también
con francia por ejemplo hay un éxito de
los quesos italianos
supera el éxito de los quesos franceses
esto no es por un tema de calidad pero
es un tema de comprensión del producto y
creo que esta globalización
favorece este tipo de productos como
tiene y tales como tienen otros países
hace poco el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores francés lanzaba la campaña a
good hands with franz que pretenden este
tipo de campañas es una campaña que
surgió con la presidencia de hollande
este tipo de campañas que pretenden
aitor por uno primero políticamente
pretenden reaccionar a la sal fifty best
porque existen tiene muy mala prensa en
francia porque porque la es una idea una
creación de una revista inglesa a la
cual se reprocha de ser muy anti
francesa el city best dicen y siguen
diciendo que el primer francés está muy
mal clasificado de hecho lo mira antes
de venir el primer francés es a la
pasada que es número 25 del mundo
la reacción francesa claramente la del
poder político fue la de crear una lista
a la francesa que es la lista famosa en
la lista cuya modalidad de
jerarquización es de lo más discutible
también porque viene a contar con a
condensar ya recopilar todos los
comentarios y avisos que se encuentran
en la red sobre los restaurantes al
final todas estas listas son artefactos
políticos las del 50 best y todo esto yo
diría incluso que sólo son artefactos y
como decía como decía muy bien en mi
compañera
se representa en el oficialismo de la
cocina es el 1 por ciento de los
cocineros que van por el mundo cocinando
y luego tienes el 99 por ciento de lo
que es la realidad astronómica de un
país que queda muy por debajo de todo
eso leonardo para estas clasificaciones
hay puntos de vista es muy subjetivo
francia así queda una referencia en las
técnicas culinarias en las innovaciones
esto es claro pero por ejemplo la
tradición culinaria francesa no
corresponde clásica no corresponde hoy
siempre a las tendencias mundiales que
son de una cúpula una cocina que no es
cargada para salsas que es una cocina
liviana sana y esto algunas visiones no
hablo puede servir como italiano pero si
es un tema claro es evidente que un
chico en asia puede comer parmigiano
pero no creo que va a comer siempre
hammam vea que hablar es un producto que
a mí me gusta mucho pero no es fácil
para comprenderlo entonces estás
clasifica clasificaciones son un reflejo
de estos diferentes puntos de vista
leonardo está haciendo un buen lobby
italiano del software este programa
buena situación para francia es muy
compleja porque por un lado la comida
francesa se consideraba como la mejor
del mundo durante mucho tiempo
y esta lista de efectiva esto este
polémicas
ponen de relieve el hecho de que
cocineros más jóvenes modernos atrevidos
de otros países que con el que formaba
parte de una comida menos conocida
y van más adelante que la cocina
francesa que bueno con la versión o
buques era un poquito case osa no pero
al mismo tiempo cuando un restaurante o
una pastelería con una panadería
francesa habría en un país es un éxito
total que países dirían que están a la
cabeza del desarrollo de la diplomacia
gastronómica aitor
tuviéramos que quedarnos con
esto al principio de los años 2000 como
dijeron mis compañeros tailandia fue
paradójicamente uno de los primeros los
países del sur emergieron muchísimo con
esto no tailandia obviamente con un
patrimonio gastronómico riquísimo
pero últimamente a pesar de lo que dice
el chef peruano el ceviche es un emblema
para mí ese es el último gran plato
regional internacionalizado por ejemplo
después de eso vamos a hacer una pequeña
pausa y a la vuelta vamos a hablar de
emblemas de platos institucionalizados y
de si no se quedan a veces en el cliché
lo hablamos en seguir aquí en primera
plana hablando de diplomacia
gastronómica esta semana hasta ahora
[Música]
y
james jennifer bramble y padres del
joven que el martes disparó contra sus
compañeros en una escuela de michigan
dejando cuatro fallecidos fueron
acusados de homicidio involuntario por
comprar el arma como regalo a su hijo y
enseñarle a disparar la analizamos lo
que se sabe del caso
la variante omicron ya fue detectada en
al menos 40 países hoy confirmándose en
mexico la organización mundial de la
salud e insta a los países a estar
preparados y a fomentar la vacunación
pero reitera que no se debe entrar en
pánico
y reabrió sus puertos en cuba el primer
hotel de la isla dedicado a la comunidad
lgbt que había cerrado por la pandemia
su regreso se da en momentos en que las
autoridades cubanas estudian la
posibilidad de aprobar el matrimonio
igualitario con un nuevo código de
familia
estas son las noticias de américa en
france 24 bienvenidos comenzamos en eeuu
los padres de istán crowley el
adolescente que protagonizó un tiroteo
en una escuela secundaria en el estado
de michigan fueron acusados por la
fiscalía de homicidio involuntario
ellos le habrían regalado el arma al
adolescente andrés granadillo nos cuenta
los pormenores que hasta ahora se
conocen del caso
cargos de homicidio involuntario les han
sido imputados a los padres de it and
from el adolescente acusado de asesinar
a cuatro estudiantes y herir a otras
siete personas en la escuela secundaria
de michigan donde asistía tras abrir
fuego el 30 de noviembre
una investigación adicional reveló que
la pistola sig sauer de 9 milímetros
comprada por james mccann le estaba
guardada sin llave en un cajón del
dormitorio de james y jennifer la
pistola recuperada del tirador en la
escuela después del tiroteo
era la misma que fue comprada por su
padre james crowley el 26 de noviembre
de 2021 en presencia de su hijo
según las investigaciones de la fiscalía
jennifer y james crowley ya habrían
comprado el arma como regalo de navidad
a ethan cuatro días antes del tiroteo y
tan mostró fotos de la pistola en las
redes sociales su madre publicó al día
siguiente que los dos estaban probando
su regalo de navidad anticipado el 21 de
noviembre un maestro vio a la
adolescente buscando municiones en su
teléfono durante la clase y alertó a los
funcionarios de la escuela quienes
dejaron mensajes de voz para su madre
que no fueron contestados en la mañana
del tiroteo un maestro descubrió un
dibujo que y tan tranvía había hecho con
una pistola una bala y una silueta
humana sangrando días después del
tiroteo la comunidad no sale del asombro
de seis de adam decir que todavía estoy
en estado de shock y entumecido es
probablemente un eufemismo habiendo en
el sistema
y tan rambis será procesado como adulto
pese a ser menor de edad sus padres
quienes -según la fiscalía- desestimaron
las señales de advertencia a la mañana
del incidente enfrentan cuatro cargos
cada uno que podrían traducirse en una
condena de 15 años de prisión de ser
hallados culpables
en otras noticias la organización
mundial de la salud dijo que pese al
peligro de la variante omicron por su
alta capacidad de transmisión la
respuesta correcta no es el pánico sino
la cautela y la preparación lado ms
insistió en que aumente la capacidad de
atención médica en los países así como
el fortalecimiento de las campañas de
vacunación sobre ese tema mientras que
científicos sudafricanos aseguran que
las vacunas son efectivas contra casos
graves de la enfermedad otros gobiernos
alertan que este linaje escapa a la
inmunidad cuán preparados deberíamos
estar necesitamos estar preparados y ser
cautelosos algo que hemos estado
diciendo desde el comienzo de la
pandemia sin pánico porque estamos en
una situación diferente hoy a la que
estábamos al principio del 2020 nosotros
tenemos herramientas sabemos qué hacer
sabemos que funciona por lo que esto era
algo que esperábamos que surgieran
nuevas variantes entretanto el primer
caso de la variante o micrones de
coronavirus o fue confirmado en mexico
el paciente no está gravemente enfermo
se trata de un ciudadano de 51 años que
viajó desde
al parecer hay un
mexicano que estuvo en sudáfrica
y estoy internado en un hospital
particular
con síntomas de kobe
y le hicieron la prueba
y al parecer si ya es esta nueva
variante un juez de la corte suprema de
brasil ordenó una investigación contra
el presidente ya ir bolsonaro por haber
dicho durante una transmisión en vivo en
múltiples plataformas en octubre que las
vacunas de kobe 19 pueden aumentar las
posibilidades de contraer el sida la
decisión del magistrado alexandre de
moraes se produjo en respuesta a una
solicitud del comité de investigación
del senado que dijo que el mandatario
cometió nueve delitos relacionados con
su manejo ampliamente criticado de la
pandemia de coronavirus
en venezuela muchas personas aseguran
que el bono de navidad que reciben
anualmente los trabajadores se ha
reducido hasta niveles insignificantes
la hiperinflación que sufre el país
desde hace cuatro años ha golpeado
directamente al poder adquisitivo con
pablo lo comí nos cuenta más
bono de navidad aguinaldo o alivio
económico lo que antes era una ayuda
financiera en época de fiestas
decembrinas para muchas familias
venezolanas hoy la super inflación del
país ahogado casi por completo esta
remuneración adicional años anteriores
fue ganada bastante la utilidad cobra 49
y de verdad que ganaban compra de todo
hasta ahora por fin pero no confío de
que en algún momento tiene que pasar y
aquí todo el venezolano tiene que
recibir como se lo merece la antigua
costumbre de hacer muchas compras
realizar celebraciones especiales y dar
regalos en el último mes del año se ha
relegado cada vez más con la devaluación
de la moneda nacional el bolívar ha
sufrido tres reconversiones en los
últimos 13 años y aún así no ha resuelto
el problema económico del país que
cuenta con una inflación de mil 258 por
ciento según cifras del observatorio
venezolano de finanzas actualmente el
salario mínimo es de 7 bolívares
equivalentes a 1,5 dólares en diciembre
los trabajadores deben recibir 28
bolívares adicionales es decir 6 dólares
calculados con la tasa oficial pero en
venezuela
con este tema de la hiperinflación y la
destrucción de los salarios se puede
llamar salario a lo que está sobre todo
en el sector público entonces el
beneficio es insignificante según un
estudio de la universidad católica
andrés bello el nivel de informalidad
laboral en venezuela se ubica en un 84,5
por ciento los salarios han perdido
tanto valor que los venezolanos afirman
que ni con bonos o beneficios extra
pueden mejorar su situación
el observatorio cubano de derechos
humanos denunció más de mil acciones que
calificó de represivas por parte del
gobierno en noviembre el organismo
contabilizó 197 detenciones arbitrarias
el mes pasado según un informe divulgado
por la organización también se
intensificaron las acciones para impedir
la protesta pacífica como sucedió el 15
ene con 487 casos de vigilancia policial
en viviendas de activistas y 182
citaciones policiales
y para el cierre el primer hotel el gp y
más en cuba reabrió sus puertas a los
turistas se trata del gran motor rainbow
inaugurado en diciembre de 2019 pero
cerrado rápidamente por la pandemia de
kobe 19 desde hace pocos días decenas de
turistas han llegado a disfrutar el
lugar informe de andrea maya
[Música]
fiestas de espuma espectáculos de baile
o una tarde en la piscina el gran motor
rainbow es el primer hotel el eje de
cuba que tras cerrar sus puertas por la
pandemia de coves 19 vuelve a dar la
bienvenida a turistas de todo el mundo
es decir en el acto y justamente en una
de las paredes y también en nuestro lo
vi como identificativo de que trabajamos
orientados a la comunidad
una locación una instalación donde la
comunidad se sienta protegida se sienta
representada tras 10 meses de
confinamiento el turismo se reactivó en
juba a mediados de noviembre los
visitantes canadienses han sido los más
ácidos al lugar rodeado de playas
paradisíacas
es algo muy bueno y espero que este
lugar inspira al gobierno cubano para
generar cambios para la comunidad lgtb y
sus derechos espero que esto sea un
cambio positivo para la isla en cuba' un
nuevo código de familia que permitiría
el matrimonio igualitario podría ser
sancionado por la asamblea nacional este
mismo año y sometido a referendo
nacional en 2022 sin embargo la unión
entre personas del mismo sexo es una
propuesta que lleva años estancada pues
los estigmas persisten en la sociedad
cubana en la última década la isla ha
logrado grandes avances para la
comunidad lgtb pero su lucha continúa a
pesar del rechazo de grupos evangélicos
y otros sectores de la sociedad
en france 24 punto coma más noticias
siga con nosotros
[Música]
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de diplomacia gastronómica lo
hacemos con adif ahora alfonso cronista
en la publicación de footing con mi
compañero a leonardo martinelli
corresponsal del diario italiano la
stampa y con carolynn champions
especialista gastronómica y este auto de
cine como exploradora de sabores que nos
explicado antes antes de ir a la pausa
mi compañera editora hablaba del ceviche
y lo definía como el último gran plato
gastronómico emblema
abrió otros ejemplos equiparables el
ceviche normalmente el sushi por ejemplo
sí que de repente que es un plato que se
come no tan a menudo en japon y de
regalar un bombo en el mundo entero date
cuenta que incluso sushi es que se
inventan en el california roll
reconocemos todo es un invento de
toronto que tiene un nombre californiano
inspirado un plato japonés es un plato
internacionalizada es un plato
mundializado y lo que el ceviche para mí
es el último gran plato que conecta
muchísimo con las aspiraciones
culinarias y gastronómicas de la gente
pero luego a la hora de exportar imagen
país vemos platos que se
internacionalizan y platos también que
derivan en otra cosa por ejemplo la
pizza italiana todos sabemos américa un
poco tiene que ver con lo que se come
uno en nápoles si ve el caso también del
sucia porque es
bueno para los japoneses fundada una
revolución cuando empezaron a poner la
palta la mayonesa todo eso y si con la
pizza fue muy difícil por los italianos
es que la pizza con ganas
sería americana de llevarla pero yo creo
que los italianos mirando mucho al
negocio se ampara business is business y
mucho más que los franceses de otros
países entonces puede ser también un
límite de los italianos
[Música]
vemos este equilibrio entre lo que es el
business lo que es la tradición como hay
gente a lo mejor que lo mira más como
hay gente que es más pragmática para
estas cosas
bueno la pizza italiana hace
ahora mismo
por ejemplo en parís
viene a ser más purista si es verdad
posterior también con el suya en poco
esta tendencia que después se descubre
también el original real principal en
adaptación porque es un fenómeno de
globalización entonces la globalización
lleva a la adaptación comercial también
y son platos muy populares pero muy cara
a la pizza purista en parís demasiado
conversaciones para llevar otro ejemplo
es la cocina mexicana que poco tiene que
ver con el tex mex es decir como algunos
platos emblemáticos luego se van no sé
si llamarlo pervirtiendo a través de la
mundialización
algo así no méxico tiene obviamente una
tradición culinaria fantástica
fascinante y creo que méxico invierte
bastante en software culinario
a través de sus grandes figuras grandes
es de sus productos bueno sabemos que
obviamente también es un asunto
comercial sabemos que méxico por ejemplo
vende pues toneladas y millones de
productos alimenticios a los eeuu yo
creo que el negocio sea es un elemento
importante en que esta diplomacia en
este tipo de comercio el precursor de
toda esta diplomacia sería no sé si
llamarla fast food pensemos en una gran
marca como mcdonald's para bien y para
mal está asociada a la imagen de eeuu y
lo he estado durante los últimos
decenios
podríamos hablar de precursor de todo lo
que hablamos hoy o más bien de una
consecuencia de la mundialización y de
la globalización
bueno como
me parece que los estados unidos siempre
han utilizado
soft pauer con el charles o con
hollywood
la cocacola y todo esto y al mismo
tiempo es un símbolo de la globalización
claro no es el símbolo de una
gastronomía es diferente no estoy segura
de que cuando ves un mcdonald tienes el
deseo de ir a visitar eeuu por eso lo
que es muy distinto con perú la comida
de perú que ahora se exporta mucho con
una restaurante muy famosos te da la
gana de ir a visitar perú otro ámbito de
importancia de la diplomacia
gastronómica es por ejemplo el de la
seducción cuando por ejemplo hay visitas
de estado como se diseñan estos menús
cuando hay una visita importante
imaginemos en el elíseo qué pasa ahí
pues mira depende mucho del presidente
de turno yo entrevisté hace poco a un
señor que fue cocinero del elíseo
programa me comentaba que
paradójicamente es laxo detestaba las
comidas
las grandes comidas internacionales
cuando era un comilón le encantaba ser
un bombín estaba a comer solo así le
gustaba comer solo entonces ha
organizado muy pocas cenas así
multitudinarias depende de cada uno es
sabido es verdad que los de buen comer
por ejemplo la cosa de rebañar el plato
con el pan eso no lo puedes hacer no
mucho es obviamente una etiqueta
extremadamente sensible protocolaria
tensa esa quita un poco la magia eso le
quitará marlon brando con saco y en
francés de que él no tomaba vino
entonces le sacaban a las ventosas
botellas de vino en las probaba madre de
dios madre mía qué quiere errores no se
pueden cometer con en este tipo de cosas
en este tipo de planificaciones con el
pan
es una lástima porque es mejor pero yo
leí una vez que en el elíseo otra cosa
es por ejemplo en las baguettes y la
harina que hay en las baguettes hay que
eliminarla porque pueden manchar las
chaquetas de los jefes de estado este
tipo de detalles son se cuidan a la
perfección en un país como francia
reuters o yo creo que es el resto de lo
que de como decir de la
en un arco filia francesas y una especie
de etiqueta que tiene más que ver con
las tradiciones monárquicas que
realmente republicanas es lo propio de
francia por ejemplo leí no sé dónde que
si comparas los gastos en etiqueta de
mesa de francia y de alemania son es
cien veces inferior en alemania por
ejemplo
podríamos decir que la castro de plom
asia es una rama del turismo
si por seguro no solo pero por sí pero
por seguro y hay que saber que la
primera industria del mundo hoy es el
turismo exacto y la gastronomía trae
como pocos atractivos de un país no y
eso me parece algo revolucionario porque
hace 20 años no nunca nadie se
va a visitar un país solo para comer
bien vas para las playas es para el
tiempo para los paisajes paisajes y todo
esto pero no para la comida y hoy sí
claro que eso es un cambio muy
interesante leonardo saltos
revolucionarios y hay casos interesantes
que lo corea del sur por ejemplo es un
país donde el turismo internacional
aumentó mucho y creo que está
relacionado a la comida coreana que fue
una sorpresa porque por muchos años se
miraba sobre todo a la cocina japonesa
como cocina globalizada y cuando se iba
yo estuve una vez en corea del sur hace
20 años los coreanos que llevaban al
restaurante japonés para mostrar la
cocina japonesa
y fue una sorpresa alguna vez hay
sorpresa que no aunque sí creo que en el
caso de corea del sur también hay una
cocina simple que se puede bastante sana
y que se puede comprender fácilmente yo
creo que esta es la llave del éxito de
la gastronomía hoy también la llave de
la de la utilización de la gastronomía
como estos power además haciendo que una
de las claves del éxito de la
gastronomía también debe ser adaptarse a
las nuevas tendencias a las nuevas
sensibilidades también de tipo político
como el medio ambiente como por ejemplo
lo que es el veganismo por ejemplo habrá
cocinas que se adapten mejor a las
nuevas sensibilidades sociales no en
claro la japonesa o la italiana por
ejemplo se adaptan mejores que otras
cocinas esto es claro la argentina con
el veganismo lo tiene más complicado
queremos que esté implicado aunque si es
un software por argentina también las
oficinas yo creo que es un país que fue
exitoso en este en este sentido y brasil
fue muy menos exitoso éste también me
impresionó tradicional por ejemplo creo
que hay razones que se pueden individual
aitor mediante acción por ejemplo como
sea internacional internacionaliza un
producto como el 'chino' es un producto
del altiplano por el verano que se
cultiva bastante poco y que en pocos
años se ha convertido en un fenómeno
mundial con muy buena imagen que de
repente se nacionalizan con una imagen
muy yo sé que incluso en ella hay un
debate político en bolivia que bolivia
quiere crear una patente de quinoa
boliviano porque hay producciones
ilegales semi legales en perú o sea que
es si el que no representa algo de la
modernidad no vegetal muy sano es muy
nutritivo
con muchas proteínas que se puede
transformar de bastantes maneras o que
se adapta de bastantes maneras antes
lean las portadas que el gobierno
italiano leonardo aseguró que la
promoción de su gastronomía en el mundo
es una prioridad de la diplomacia
económica ya que expresa cultura
investigación e innovación del país
hablamos de la vitrina de sectores tan
importantes y de tanto peso en el pib de
un país como la agricultura el turismo o
la ciencia
todos incluidos en este asunto y en el
caso la agricultura la industria
agropecuaria es muy importante es
importante porque con todos los
problemas que italia tiene decimos que
era el instrumento para desarrollarse es
su industria que es siempre una
industria muy muy fuerte industria
agroalimentaria también hay casos muy
interesantes del éxito de la mozzarella
que tuvo un instrumento fue un
instrumento de desarrollo de algunas
zonas del sur de italia el par millón en
el norte la paz está cerca por ejemplo
que uno puede imaginar que es siempre el
primer productor del mundo la italia
entonces es si eso es un elemento y hay
un elemento económico muy importante yo
creo que italia no es muy buena en la
planificación de creo que
esto tema de la de la diplomacia
gastronómica es algo que se
aprovecha de una tendencia positiva yo
creo que es esto la descubrió también un
poco más más tarde pero descubrió que es
como la moda un software importante a
partir de lo que de un elemento
revolucionario por ejemplo para atraer
turistas entendemos que cada de los
estados están invirtiendo más en este
asunto claro que sí por ejemplo teilón
da
invierto ha invertido
invertido perdido 42 millones de euros
sólo para traer la guía misma en su
propio país en
bueno
y más inversión aún en tiempos de kobe
para países que tienen y en los cuales
una parte importante del pib tiene que
ver con el turismo que se quedado
estancados sin turistas pues hay que ya
preparar el post kobe y me imagino y hay
que ya a dar ganas a la gente de
visitar esos países no sé si podemos
medir el impacto político de la
gastrónoma hacia de alguna forma lo
podemos medir a lo mejor
en dinero en el número de turistas que
llegan a las puertas de un país se puede
medir el éxito de campañas como las que
hemos visto hoy leonardo lo que que es
difícil yo antes decía que en italia de
la facturación de la industria
alimentaria es muy importante creo que
la gastronomía la diplomacia
gastronómica es un instrumento de
desarrollo de eso pero creo que
dar números precisos muy es muy difícil
pero seguramente lo verán lo veamos
durante los próximos tiempos durante los
próximos años veamos números precisos
porque aseguran de los gobiernos las
cancillerías en esto en esto metan un
importante vínculo económico no en todo
lo que estamos hablando hoy no sí sí sin
duda siempre es complicado saber cuál es
la repercusión directa de este tipo de
inversión pero pero pero sí sí que la
hay sé que la mente está claro y a lo
mejor en los años venideros
efectivamente se podrá medir medir mejor
poniendo esos si ustedes pero yo desde
luego me quedo con mucha hambre después
de este programa que hemos hecho hoy
27 muchísimas gracias a los tres a todos
ustedes hasta la próxima semana en
primera plana gracias
[Música]